the jurogan experience i
had a dentist in dallas when i was a kid
he used to hypnotize
people and i you know he's gonna
drill a cavity for me and i said i'd
like for you to hypnotize me and
so it was you know your your mouth is
feeling like a block of wood
your mouth is feeling like a block of
wood nurse i think he's ready and i said
no i'm not
give me the novocaine but then
the only other time that i had what was
kind of
success in being hypnotized was
um in
1983
it was the 20th anniversary of the
kennedy assassination
and i had grown up in dallas during the
assassination
there was a story that was quite widely
circulated
that school children in dallas had
laughed when they heard the news
and i wasn't sure that i hadn't been one
of them
i remember being astonished
i remember gaping i remember you know
did a ha ha come out of my mouth i don't
know if
if it did you know i but i
i think i smiled in amazement i'm not
really sure i mean you have to
go back to what dallas was like at that
time it was
hysterical you know the politics were
off the rails and
kennedy was hated although not in my
family
but you know there was this sense of uh
dallas as being a separate entity
from the rest of the country and that
kennedy was the enemy
and i was anxious that maybe
i had been one of those people that
laughed and so i had a friend who
was a therapist who did
uh hypnosis and i asked her to hypnotize
me and see if she could take me back to
the classroom
and and help me remember
and so she
put me under regressed my memories you
know to the point that i hear the
ding ding the pa system and the choked
voice of our
principal coming on and did she tell you
you're hearing these things do you know
just i know she's asking me you know
what i could recall
yeah what do i recall and i i remember
seeing you know
the face of my friend steve zink
one of my classmates in the algebra
class and
i couldn't get it
myself and so she gave me a
post-hypnotic suggestion that i would
have a dream
and it would reveal to me uh
what i what i had experienced and so
i did have a very vivid dream and
it was i was flying
in a helicopter over the canopy of what
i thought was vietnam jungle
and you were looking for a child and
uh i saw it in the top of a canopy just
lying on top of the
tree and as we got closer i realized it
was actually just a doll with these
little
x eyes and that was the dream
and i decided from that that i was
that the me that i thought
you know might have laughed was just a
figment you know an effigy of some sort
and that you know i really hadn't
laughed uh
you'd have to understand what a scarring
experience it was to have been
from dallas at that period of time and
how everybody in the world hated you
such a strange thing to try to
remember what was your reaction and
how old are you at the time 13 i guess
but it's a very strange thing did you
feel like
you felt guilt at the possibility that
you had laughed
yeah i did i didn't want to be one of
those people yeah
and uh you know i have friends from
dallas who do remember
people in their classroom laughing and
my experience that i
you know the real memory i have of it is
that people looked around and just
stunned astonishment and part of the
astonishment i think was that we just
thought nothing would ever happen in
dallas
it was you know on the one hand it was
totally crazy
in the other hand it was totally
paralyzed you know
there was just a sense the conformity
was so
powerful that you know you felt
imprisoned
by uh the sameness of every day every
thought
uh you know just this very very rigid
environment
so some spectacularly unique occurrence
like the president getting assassinated
right in dealey plaza just seemed
impossible
oddly enough no i mean that was a thing
you know if it's going to happen
anywhere
it seemed like dallas would be the right
because they hated canada and even that
morning i went out to get the newspaper
and there was that famous ad
welcomed mr kennedy to dallas you know
just this
bleak thing and then there was uh
you know it's just how is it bleak oh it
made all these absurd
charges about you know his aiding
communists and so on and race you know
race they had a racist undertone to it
uh it was there was
yeah there it is yeah it shows up
oh you can see how it can't read all
that well it says welcome mr kennedy to
dallas
it's you can see that it is saying a
city a city
it's about who we are and we are not you
and uh it was uh uh
it was almost and then there in the same
newspaper maybe your guy can find it
there is a wanted oh no wait a minute
it's separate
it was on top of the newspaper was a
wanted poster for
kennedy with full face and profile
somebody had placed it on top of that
and uh like wanted for treason or
something like that
there yeah that was on our doorstep that
morning
so uh
that was the atmosphere of dallas
in 1963. wow there was a
there was a you know adoles stevenson
had come
to dallas in october the month before
to make a speech about the united
nations and he was the un ambassador
and he was assaulted and
he went out to greet the crowd he was
booed down
and by the way i think lee harvey oswald
was in the audience that night
but he went out and to try to talk
to the crowd and stanley marcus was his
escort and he said don't
don't try that ally you know this is
crazy and but
people were really worked up they you
know this woman was holding a sign
and she wrapped it down on top of
ambassador stevenson's
head the sign said if you seek jesus
seek peace ask jesus
so that's i at some reason that that
always
struck me as the dallas and i just want
to say
as i'm talking about dallas in the past
dallas of today
is a totally different place and i think
in
some ways you know it was so chastened
and
humbled by that horrible experience
i've said in the past if kennedy had to
die somewhere i'm grateful he did in
dallas
because it made that city a far better
place
and you remember the police killings a
few years ago
nine cops the way
it was a block away from the dealey
plaza
but the way in which that city handled
that tragedy
by comparison was so magnificent you
know i just
i have a lot of admiration for the city
that dallas has become
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience